-Welcome back
to "Late Night," everybody.
We are here with Leslie Jones.
-Yes!
-This is very exciting.
You are -- starting tomorrow...
-Yes.
-...you are hosting
"The Daily Show" for 3 nights.
Are you excited to take on
this challenge?
-Yeah, I'm excited
that they don't know
what they're getting into.
-I'm thrilled. I'm looking
forward to seeing it.
-I'm just -- I just want to
see what I'm-a do.
-Yeah.
-Well, I mean --
-I mean, you've been behind
a desk before.
Obviously, you did a lot of
stuff at "Weekend Update."
You've hosted before.
You've filled in for Ellen.
-Mm-hmm.
-So I think it ticks
a lot of boxes.
And obviously, that staff is
still there in place.
They're talented people.
-They're great, too.
They're actually awesome.
They've been very helpful.
They've, you know, given us
great options and ideas
and being very supportive.
-Was there anything you
brought in where you said,
"Hey, I want to address
stories like this?"
-Yes. Yes.
There's a line of things
I'm going to --
I can't tell you,
but, you know,
it's going to be good.
It's going to be good.
We're going to be touching
some subjects.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm very much looking
forward to the next 3 nights.
It's also Oscars season,
and I do enjoy talking to you
about the media you've consumed
over the course of the year.
-Yes.
-Are there any movies
you're rooting for,
any movies you loved this year?
-You know what's so crazy?
Like, they were asking me that,
and I was like,
"Oh, my God, what movies?"
It's weird. This is so random.
"The Menu."
-"The Menu?"
[ Cheering ]
We have "Menu" fans here.
-Yo, yo, have y'all seen that?
[ Audience shouts "Yes" ]
-Look at this.
-Okay.
First of all,
the title is very misleading.
So I thought it was going to be
about a chef that they was
trying to bring back,
and, like, he was old.
He went and lived on an island
and started cooking.
And the girl,
they was going to go over
there and get him
and bring him back.
-I mean I do -- that movie
sounds awesome, too.
-Yeah, but that's not what
happened on "The Menu."
It was like, oh, hell no!
And there was no Black people
in that movie.
-And there were no Black people
-Because don't no Black people
go to no island
and eat like that.
It was like, "So it's just
exclusive? Oh, no.
So I can't use my phone?
Oh, no, no."
-So if I told you
there was a great restaurant
I wanted to take you to,
but we had to take a ferry
to get there, you would be --
that would be a hard no for you?
-Do you actually think
I'm-a to believe
another White person
and get on a boat?
[ Audience laughs ]
Fool me once, my fault.
Fool me twice...
[ Audience laughs ]
-I should note that one
of our writers, Seth Reese,
co-wrote that movie.
-Really?
-Yeah, "The Menu."
A "Late Night" writer.
-It was really -- I hope he
gets some -- some love for it,
some recognition for it.
-I think he's already
gotten more than enough
personally but --
-You know, you've always been
kind of a super hater.
-I mean -- I -- Thanks.
It's very nice of you to say.
[ Laughter ]
I think the last time
you were here,
I had not watched "Euphoria."
You had.
You love "Euphoria."
I've watched it now.
I'm totally on board.
So I get it.
-Do you get it now?
-I get it now.
-But, like, how much of a nerd
are you now?
Because, like, I was a complete
nerd after I watched that.
I was like, "Oh, I was a goody
two shoes in high school."
-Oh, yeah.
-They are doing stuff I didn't
do until I was, like, 37.
-Yeah.
-[ Chuckles ]
-I took --
I hope I'm not overreacting.
I took my three kids after I saw
it, and I put them in a cabin
in the woods.
They're still there.
-Yeah, exactly. Exactly.
-I'm like, you're not
allowed to be around other kids.
-No, not them kids.
Not them kids.
-Those kids, they're --
-Man. Ah, man.
Ah, man. Ah, man.
That one scene where Rue tore
the door down --
-Yeah.
-I was like, "Oh, my dad --
my dad would have been, like,
calling the funeral homes
like, "So how long
can you get a coffin
because I'm about
to kill this girl.
She just -- she just broke
a door in my house."
Yeah, yeah.
-I like that of all the
terrible things
they do on that show,
the line that would cross
for your dad
is a door was broken.
-Yes. Thank you!
Because first of all, these
kids, they just -- you know,
kids is just -- they just water
it down from the generations.
So it's like,
you think I don't want --
my mom would be like, "Drugs?!
You think I don't want
to be high, Leslie?!
to be high?!
Get yo ass in the kitchen!"
[ Audience laughs ]
-That's a good way
of looking at it.
-And I would be clean as hell.
-Yeah. That is a good way of
looking at it.
Think about it.
You think the parents are upset
because they're worried about
their kids' safety,
but they're just jealous.
-They're just basically like,
"You spent too much time."
Like, it was just, like,
no cleaning of the house.
She wasn't responsible
for nothing.
-No.
-You need to give that girl
some chores.
-Yeah.
Rue needs a chore board!
-She -- Rue -- No.
Rue need to be strangled
one good time.
She need -- her mom need
to grab her and go --
[ Laughter ]
[ Gasps ]
-I will say that show is
"Game of Thrones" for parents.
-Oh, my God.
-Like that show is way --
-If I was a parent and
I saw that, I would do like --
I would just like --the
conversation I would have
with my child would be like,
"Who are you dating?
What are y'all doing?"
-Yeah.
-"What are you drinking?"
I would literally drug test
my kid every day.
I'd be like, "No, come in here
and piss in this cup.
You was out with that girl,
that girl with the nails?
No, bring your ass in here.
No. No.
The blonde chick?
No. Come here.
Come here. Let me smell you."
[ Laughter ]
-This is also very exciting --
no surprise to anybody,
you're getting out on the road.
You're doing some stand-up
dates.
-Yes.
-Where are you going to be?
Is there anywhere
we can see you?
-Damn, I have to remember
that?
Okay. Uh...
Atlantic City. I know I'm going
to be in Atlantic City.
-You know what? We're going to
throw it up on the screen.
-Please do.
I wish you would have said that
before I tried to guess
my schedule.
-No, it's great. You obviously
are really excited.
-You love to see me.
-Before you -- before you go
onstage, double check
so you don't walk out and be
like, "It's great to be
in Atlantic City when you're in,
like, Tallahassee."
-I've done that so many times.
-Have you done it before?
-Yes. Oh, my God.
I was on the Kat tour,
and I walked out -- [ Laughs ]
I walked out, and I was like,
"What's up, Columbus?"
They was like, "Boo, bitch."
[ Laughter ]
-That is the thing about you,
and knowing the enthusiasm
you said it,
none of them thought
it was an honest mistake.
-It was like it was --
What's up?
What's up? What's up?
What's up? What's up, Columbus?
"Boo!"
[ Laughter ]
-Leslie, I am so excited
for this week.
"Daily Show" doesn't know how
lucky they are.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Tomorrow night, she'll be on
through Thursday, 11:00 P.M.
on Comedy Central.
Check out "The [bleep]
with Leslie and Lenny"
wherever you get your podcasts.
We'll be right back
with Rosie Perez, everybody.